as a student we all are curious there's
so much happening AI is coming layoffs
are happening so how we can be relevant
for the future sense if you have the
ambition and the intent you'll find it I
think the bigger thing all of you need
to do is build relationships with each
other let me promise you one thing even
with all of my observing nothing has
been more impactful than the
relationships I've made so instead of
worrying about or trying to overthink
what you should be doing right now is
spending time with each other to build
relationships because that's what's
actually to get you to a place that you
want to end up because right now in this
little group there's two or three people
here that are destined to do very
important things and if you actually
have a relationship with them instead of
just being a random classmate that never
had a relationship that individual is
going to be able to help you so I think
in student life it's not about the
information you're going to learn it's
not about the anxiety of the future it's
about going deep into the relationships
while you have time to go deep in
relationship you don't have families now
you have time to invest in each other
and everyone misses it that's what you
should be doing